[Music]
well good evening welcome to a very
special extended two-hour edition of
Piers Morgan uncensored well that was
magic wasn't it
I mean I've been to a lot of events in
my time I've never been to anything like
what happened in London today at the
Queen's funeral it was the single most
spine tingling extraordinary
extravaganza
of Pomp and pageantry and Remembrance
commemoration and celebration of this
unique woman
London felt like the center of the world
Emperors presidents kings and queens
hundreds of thousands of mourners
pilgrims lining the streets billions
watching around the world we all stopped
we all came together we all said goodbye
goodbye to an exceptional lady whose
service Duty and Majesty will forever be
unrivaled a rock of stability in a
tumultuous world that changes fast and
so often feels fractured even fragile
we also say goodbye to an Era to an age
and we did it in the most extraordinary
style every boot polished every Jewel
glistening not a foot or a feather out
of place
the monarchy and our military
the face of Britain shows to the world
and to the thousands of service men and
women who carried out today's ceremonies
with such electrifying Precision it was
utterly faultless I paid tribute to all
of you
you carried the weight of history on
your shoulders
you were perfect
it was a service and a ceremony and A
procession
not only fit for a queen but for our
Queen in my opinion the queen
and that's no small feat amid the grief
and gratitude there was gravitas there's
probably nobody else who could bring
together such an extraordinary assembly
of world leaders probably won't ever be
this again
criticism II wasn't just a historic
figure herself she transcended history
and it's history that makes Britain and
these State occasions unique in the
world
take the funeral service itself for
Westminster Abbey 30 kings and queens
are buried there almost every Monarch
since William the Conqueror had their
coronation there it's where the late
Queen herself was married and crowned
where she marked the death of her own
husband the memorial this year the state
gun Carriage carrying her coffin was
pulled by Royal Navy sailors not horses
because the great Queen Victoria's
horses were spooked by the cold at her
funeral now the tradition remains
there's a remarkable story in history
behind almost every detail of what we
saw today through 15 Prime Ministers and
14 U.S presidents through social
Revolution through good times and bad
there's no story it's more remarkable
than Queen Elizabeth
I think we all felt the weight of that
history today we shared it with historic
Gathering of world leaders with all
these people watching from every corner
of the world but somehow it still felt
personal didn't it like we were saying
goodbye to somebody we all knew even
though very few of us had much
connection with the queen
her life belonged to all of us now it
belongs to history
the monarchy will go on in the age of
King Charles any questions of that have
surely been vanquished by the
outpourings of emotion and respect in
these days of national mourning because
politicians come and go they fight
elections by cutting deals and dividing
us telling lies sometimes but they're
all family holds us together they're the
glue of Great Britain they keep our
sense of nation and identity separate
from The Fray
nobody has ever or I suspect will ever
do it better than this Queen Elizabeth
II
born as the only niece to an unmarried
Heir she was ever supposed to be a
monarch
by Quirk of Fate she ultimately became
our greatest ever Monarch and the
greatest Britain and how lucky we are
that she did tonight we say a final
solemn goodbye to her majesty who has
been buried at a private service with
her family in a few minutes time and we
get one last chance after 10
extraordinary days to say these simple
words thank you your majesty